alors prêts à élire le prochain député
au parlement européen
mais au juste c'est quoi le parlement
européen au parlement ils sont 7 151
députés
il siège à strasbourg mais à l'origine
les citoyens européens ne léser lisez
pas il y avait bien une assemblée
commune au tout début en 1952 devenu
assemblée parlementaire en 1958 puis
parlement européen en 1979 avec pour la
première fois des députés élus au
suffrage universel 410 député à l'époque
élu pour cinq ans pour les présider en
1979 l'hémicycle a choisi une femme
alors ça c'est super une française
tellement longtemps
simone veil avec les élargissement
progressif de l'union ils sont
aujourd'hui 751 députés mais alors que
font tous ces gens à strasbourg
non c'est quand même plus sérieux que ça
fait un parlement parlement européen et
pourtant nous n'y allons pas pour faire
des lois pas pour faire les lois non
mais pour les voter les textes c'est la
commission européenne à bruxelles qui
les rédigent puis le parlement débat de
leur contenu propose des modifications
et enfin les votes
lorsque je vote oui je mets le pouce en
l'air lorsque nous nous abstenons ch
mais moi ma main comme ça et lorsque
nous votons contre ce mec à moi mais
tout le monde doit campo l'autre rôle de
député européen et pas des moindres
étudié en profondeur les textes de la
commission
ils sont répartis dans divers groupes
chacun a sa spécialité et les députés
apportent leurs propres propositions au
texte d'origine d'investissement
personnel beaucoup de temps consacré
aussi à des déplacements les décisions
de l'europe sont ensuite reprises ou
décliner dans les états membres
les deux tiers des textes votés à
l'assemblée nationale à paris ne sont
plus que les simples déclinaisons disent
que j'ai voté ici
côté salaire d'importantes disparités
selon les pays
exemple début 2009
les mieux payés sans les italiens avec
11000 euros nets en bas de l'échelle les
bulgares doivent se contenter de 150
euros par mois mais un peu plus d'équité
depuis juin 2009
c'est pas trop pour tout le monde est
désormais logé à la même enseigne en
chaque eurodéputé touché 6611 euros nets
pour 4 à 8 jours en séance par mois
[Musique]